James Schneider is a leading organizer
of the group and he joins me now in a
very good morning to mr. Schneider well
there are some specific charges there in
a gender one let's start with a specific
one then it's been talked about for a
while D selecting MPs who don't appear
loyal to mr. Corbyn momentum has been
extremely clear all the way through
we're not campaigning for any D
selections and we're not campaigning for
man that jury selection the bit in the
clique that you don't see beforehand
Owen Smith is talking about a
documentary which is due to air tomorrow
which he hasn't seen and you haven't
seen and I haven't seen but the
allegations that are put in that that
had been put taut or not even what he
said there that we're parently plotting
all over the country for decisions it
simply isn't the case well I mean some
of the other allegations you're right it
hasn't been broadcast yet but some of
the other allegations that have been
released in advance mr. Smith alluding
to them there that you are there are
parallels with the militant group in
there the 1980s an entry Esparta who
wants to to take over the Labor Party to
hollow it out and for you to control it
I mean that's what Owen said on Friday
in a in a speech which is really
unfortunate and some people are upset by
it but what we've said is come a meet us
come and meet our members and let's
clear up any misconceptions that you
have because a lot of our members they
weren't born when militant was going on
they don't have the same politics where
18,000 members in momentum 150,000
supporters overwhelmingly are members of
the Labor Party if they're not members
of Labor Party they are affiliate
affiliated through their trade union or
their supporters this is a labor
movement organization which is trying to
make the labor party more participatory
more democratic and more campaigning so
I mean much looser not a Trotsky it's
Trotskyite sect who are plotting to take
things over a looser group coalescing
around the leadership of jeremy corbyn
and some of his ideals is that what
you're telling me I mean I'm not sure
how you mean by looser group and Trotsky
I mean I'm not really sure how they work
I'm not part of them I think they're
really very marginal turn not only the
Labour Party but British politics full
stop but yes it's a group of people who
are inspiring enthused by the Jeremy
Corbyn and his ideas
who want to go and take those to make
the Labour Party a force for change even
stronger force a change in the country
win elections and transvestites take all
that out of it and then you I mean on
the issue of de selection individually
constituencies may decide that they're
going a different way from their MPs
beliefs and they they'd like a different
one selections are a matter for local
party members and affiliates that's
absolutely right and that's that that's
their right but that's not the role for
momentum to be campaigning for one
particular D selection or another but
then they would have conversations
presumably with other activists in other
constituency saying how do you do it
what should we do should we get labour
members as rules laid out through Party
conference into the National Executive
Committee have the right through agreed
processes to select their candidates
that's not weird that's not strange
that's not abusive that's a cornerstone
of representative democracy that you can
have some say over who your
representatives are now that's one thing
that's being suggested that because that
is American I mean but just on that
correct me if I'm wrong but aren't
underrepresented of democracy or have
the MPS for a constituency meant to
represent all constituents not just the
party members that they recommend
absolutely but a Labour MP is a
representative of the Labour Party
elected by their members and affiliates
in their area they're also the elected
MP for all of their constituents it's
the same for any Tory MP or or any other
MP because they come from the party they
were elected you know Jeremy Corbyn when
he's elected and Islington North or Owen
Smith whoever they're electing they're
elected as the Labour candidate so they
are doing two things they are they are
accountable back to their labour
membership they're accountable to their
constituents well in terms of our
accountability what about this this hit
list just after Jeremy Corbyn it had a
very good day was seen in there in the
House of Commons against the prime
minister Theresa May this this list
emerged is of MPs that aren't helpful
including the deputy leader Tom Watson
who's described momentum as a rabble
well I mean they're a hit list no
there's not a hit list
that's it should definitely not be
described as here this what happened was
a notes to editor of one press release
which shouldn't be sent out which went
to one journalist those
list of of occasions where MPs have been
abusive to Jeremy Corbyn or all his
supporters it's not a hit list there's
not some calculated plan it was a list
of publicly available examples of
something which were not meant to be you
say it shouldn't be sent out Shirley
Chander being compiled a list of a list
of areas where someone has been where
someone has been publicly a beautiful or
just done opposition that's not a
peculiar thing to have but the idea that
that is somehow linked to some plot to
remove them as MPs is it's just there's
no evidence of that it's just mr. Snyder
what does it exist for bareness it just
people to look out and go oh well there
they are I mean look I don't know act
accordingly
I know I that's this was not a list that
was meant to there was going to be put
out in public and what you mean actor
corny of course although both campaigns
will know who's supportive of them who
isn't support of them the ways in which
they're being supportive or not
supportive that's perfectly normal
so do you think there will be more lists
like this no I don't think they'll be
more lip like this like this I mean the
campaign apologized for a rut foo you
know accidentally putting it out no
they're not going to be more or less
like this I mean it's slightly a red
herring like okay and on this it's been
talked about for a while getting the
membership involved in policy and
selecting the shadow cabinet you see
that is the right way to go to represent
the membership I sounds very democratic
to me it sounds I mean the there are no
proposed as far as I understand it from
the observer this morning there aren't
any actual proposed being put forward
it's something that's going to be
discussed at the National Executive
Committee and there's ideas about how
much the leaders should be able to do
how much the parliamentary party should
be able to do and how much the members
should be able to do that seems like a
kind of reasonable balance a reasonable
approach to talk about those things in a
democratic party and just start we
haven't really talked about the results
the expected result that mr. Corbyn gets
back in as leader again well remains as
leader with it with a bigger majority a
bit a bigger share do you think that
then strengthens his hand and says to
those that have opposed him particularly
members of the parliamentary Labour
Party shut up support him he is your
leader now I wouldn't say it says shut
up I think that's that's wrong I think
what it does say you know if Jeremy wins
it does say look it was a
this is the direction that the party is
going on the changes that the party is
undertaking to which changes their
policy and to become more member led
that's what the members want and there
is I think a duty incumbent on everyone
to respect that result in some way now
that doesn't mean you just fall in line
and you say we agree with everything and
everything's right but what's the way in
which we criticize let's let's have
debates about policy let's say well
actually we don't like this policy we'd
like it to do likely to be more like
this rather than trying to undermine
that the whole leadership the party
needs to come together because when we
come together we're able to take on the
Tories if those people on this list
these MPs on this list took the decision
to voluntarily leave you wouldn't
propose them what it's about let's
inform a new party absolutely but oppose
that it would be it's a real it's a real
problem for the Labour Party if there's
if there's a split no one wants to see
that and you want to see these people
stay see within the Labour Party yeah I
don't want to see any of them Neath the
Labour Party of course not